mes chers
amis en ce jour fondateur les prises de
parole sont nombreuses et exprime la
diversité diversité des
sensibilités diversité des physiques qui
suffit
d'observericti moi-même Édouard Coural
ce matin mais au-delà de nos différences
de nos expressions de nos gabarits nous
avons tous une seule grande et
indispensable ambition commune redresser
la France
en protégeant en réaffirmant en
renforçant ses valeurs
républicaines parmi les défis lancés à
notre société c'était vrai il y a celui
de l'autorité l'autorité c'est la force
de la loi le respect des institutions et
la protection de chacun et cette valeur
républicaine est aujourd'hui oubliée
dévalorisée et même dénigrée par
l'actuelle majorité la politique
d'immigration en est has un des tristes
exemples autorité ce n'est pas la
confusion face à l'immigration
clandestine vous en souvenez peut-être
François Hollande nous avait dit dans un
premier temps que ce serait en gros une
régularisation générale puis nous avez
ensuite déclaré fièrement que cela
serait au cas par cas avant que tout
cela se termine en une régularisation
générale au cas par cas une de ses
petites habiletés à laassauce
hollandaise l'autorité ensuite ce n pas
la contradiction permanente face aux
centaines de milliers de migrants
débarquants aux portes de l'Europe le
ministre de l'Intérieur a revendiquer la
proposition de cota par la Commission
européenne soulignant même qu'elle était
largement inspirée par la France dès le
lendemain le Premier ministre indiquait
qu'il n'en était pas question pour
terminer tendez bien vos oreilles par un
courageux non au cota oui au cot part si
l'autorité ce n'est pas la confusion ce
n'est pas non plus la
faiblesse faiblesse à l'égard de tous
ceux qui ne respectent ni nos lois ni
nos règles ni nos valeur avec le
gouvernement socialiste si vous êtes en
situation irrégulière vos soins sont
totalement gratuits et les transport en
commun le sont presque autant en
supprimant la franchise de 30 € que nous
avions pourtant mise en place pour
combattre les abus et s'attaquer au
fraudeurs François Hollande a cédé par
faiblesse il n'est naturellement pas
question de laisser des personnes des
enfants en secours mais des questions
méritent d'être posées devant les
Français quelle est l'autorité d'un
gouvernement toujours plus généreux avec
ce qui fraude et toujours plus incapable
implacable et incapable avec les
Français qui contribuent par exemple au
financement de leurs soins par le ticket
modérateur quelle est l'autorité d'un
gouvernement qui augmente
considérablement le nombre des
naturalisations partant d'un principe
dévastateur que l'accession à la
nationalité française est le point de
départ du parcours d'intégration alors
que pour nous ce doit être au contraire
le point d'arrivée du parcours
d'assimilation quelle est l'autorité
d'un gouvernement qui a offert au
français le spectacle aussi inadmissible
que résible du séjour illégal dans notre
pays d'une jeune femme leonarda et de
toute sa famille nouveau symbole d'un
socialisme décrépi celle qui n'en
espérait pas temps a ainsi pu quasiment
débattre presque d'égal à égal en direct
à la télévision avec le président de la
République en faisant preuve d'autant de
faiblesse ce n'est pas seulement l'image
d'un responsable politique qui s'est
trouvé discrédité c'est malheureusement
toute une institution de la République
qui a été ridiculisée pour un un
sociologue célèbre Gustave Lebon la
compétence sans autorité est aussi
impuissante que l'autorité sans
compétence mais il avait oublié
d'étudier le 3è cas inauguré par le
pouvoir d'aujourd'hui lorsqu'il n'y a ni
autorité ni compétence lorsqu'il n'y a
ni l'un ni l'autre que reste-t-il de
l'État enfin quelle est l'autorité d'un
gouvernement qui selon la technique bien
connu du scafandrier fait sans cesse
remonter à la surface la promesse du
droit de vote des étrangers n'hésitant
pas ainsi à brader la citoyenneté
française pour s'attirer de nouvelles
clientèles mes chers amis Nicolas
Sarkozi nous invite aujourd'hui à un
nouveau départ nouveau départ qui
rappelle que l'autorité ce n'est pas
simplement une nécessité ou une volonté
mais aussi une nature et une qualité
dans le fil de l'épée le général de
gaaule avait perçu ce que lui-même
incarnait si bien certains hommes
écrivaient-il répandent de naissance un
flu d'autorité dont on ne peut discerner
au juste en quoi et consiste à
l'évidence et ce n'est pas lui faire
injure François Hollande n'est pas
concerné par ce fluide et a été épargné
mais nous aujourd'hui soyons heureux de
compter dans nos rangs tant de personnes
Alain Jup jeanpierrearin François Fillon
et tant d'autres et surtout soyons fiers
et je vous le dis en conclusion soyons
fiers d'avoir à notre tête celui qui a
la volonté la détermination l'envie et
l'autorité de l'expérience Nicolas
Sar